ah que ça fait du bien l'équipe de
France est en quart de finale de la
Coupe du Monde on les applaudit on les
applaudit
ah ça fait plaisir non mais franchement
on a eu une première mi-temps un peu
difficile on était sur splato dans salon
et on se dit ah il sait pas si simple
Giraud avait débloqué la situation et
puis un certain Kilian Mbappé et passer
par là qu'on a critiqué longtemps dans
cette deuxième période et puis il est
incroyable quoi tout simplement
incroyable bon euh c'est pas
ce qui se fait de plus français de
gagner les matchs comme ça là on a fait
les choses très sereinement quoi on n'a
pas forcément brillé mais on a été on a
été bon Florent baraco oui on était bon
en deuxième mi-temps on va pas réécrire
la première on a quand même eu très très
peur lors de la première mi-temps
x le but de Giroud juste avant la pose
un peu miner le moral des Polonais entre
temps des champs il a il a serré les
boulons de son équipe à la mi-temps et
puis voilà on a déroulé c'est vrai qu'il
y avait raison Griezmann a pris de
l'ampleur il a distribué et donc
finalement on a on s'est facilité la vie
en jouant notre jeu et en marquant ce
deuxième but puis après ce troisième but
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu raison jusqu'à
la 97e minute parce il avait parié trois
buts à zéro avec un doublette qui vient
de napper je tiens à rappeler que
l'arbitre est vénézuélien qu'il a fait
retirer le penalty et que ce titre à
juste titre parce qu'Hugo Lloris tu
avais pas le pied sur la ligne
qui est avec nous évidemment
chroniqueuse pour RTL chroniqueuse foot
avait parié sur le bon résultat bravo
qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé de
cette équipe de France elle est sereine
franchement bon première mutant un peu
difficile mais après on a déroulé quoi
elle a fait les job et en deuxième
mi-temps je l'ai trouvé très très bonne
très en place avec des juniors vraiment
qui ont pris leur rôle plus à coeur il
avait Griezmann vraiment bon à la
relance Dembélé qui s'est amélioré
également bonne décision également
coaching dédiés des champs qui décident
de sortir soit mini finalement donc je
trouve que c'est là aussi ça a donné une
bonne impulsion sur ces matchs après au
bleu même s'il a été très bon en
première période donc équipe de France
vraiment qui donne de très belles
sensations en cette première match
entier avec
contre une équipe de Pologne qui a fini
par prendre un petit peu l'eau je trouve
par la suite les Bleus ont vraiment fait
job je salue cosito qui nous demande qui
nous demande où est Martin Martin
couturier il arrive le chef du service
des sports mais Cédric allier et le
digne représentant de se servir sur ce
plateau je vous donne la parole Cédric
mais d'abord on va au Qatar Vincent
roseron est-ce que vous m'entendez
est-ce que la liaison est bonne ah les
Bleus nous ont fait plaisir est-ce
qu'ils vous ont fait plaisir à vous
aussi dans ce match
alors ils ont fait plaisir parce qu'ils
ont gagné ça c'est sûr qu'ils m'ont fait
plaisir mais c'était quand même assez
tendu on va pas dire que c'était une
balle de santé on va pas dire que
l'équipe a été sereine pendant tout le
match le but de Giro en fin de première
mi-temps qui vraiment vous l'avez dit
dans votre débrie de la mi-temps qui
vraiment nous fait énormément de bien et
juste avant le but de Mbappé on
commençait à être un peu crispé je veux
que je vous le cache pas en tribune mais
voilà tout est bien qui finit bien 3-0
puis 3 d'ailleurs puis c'est pour ce
penalty mais en tout cas mission
accomplie pour les Bleus
ils sont cliniques ces bleus vous
réagissez sur le Figaro.fr sur Youtube
vous n'hésitez pas je prends vos
questions vos réactions on en parle ici
c'est la marque de fabrique de cette
équipe de France franchement elle est
impressionnante de ce point de vue là
c'est peut-être pas flamboyant mais les
Polonais ils ont jamais espérés dans le
fond vraiment non on sentait que à la
deuxième période alors rentré sur le
terrain qui savait qu'il avait perdu
enfin moi j'ai trouvé même on était on
était on était hyper enthousiaste sur
les 20 premières minutes de la deuxième
période on s'est dit voilà ton fort faut
vite qu'on marque qu'on marque qu'on
marque on n'a pas réussi à marquer mais
on n'a jamais eu de révoltes polonaise
et puis bon bah Mbappe fait du MAP quoi
évidemment ce côté clinique Cédric
allier ça vous impressionne oui oui je
pense que c'est
c'est la seconde période est vraiment ce
qu'on veut voir des Bleus en fait il y a
ils ont ils ont un peu plus de ce prix
leur temps pour pour construire
ils ont vraiment dominé les Polonais ont
été catastrophiques dans la relance et
puis et puis la lumière est venue comme
d'habitude de Kylian Mbappé et voilà
mais on va
sur les 20 premières minutes ouais mais
et puis quand même je tiens à signalé
sur le sur le sur le but de Mbappé on a
le un contrôle de Giroud absolument
exceptionnel alors que visiblement il a
d'abord
la surface dans la surface ce nouveau
rôle de milieu défensif
donc c'est puis l'équipe de France a été
très solide bon il y a on pourra
qualifier d'anecdotique ce penalty
même s'il fait le bonheur de ma voisine
pour son pronostic et il reste
anecdotique dans la dans la manière on
n'a pas vu tout à fait d'accord on n'a
pas vu la Pologne un moment donné nous
mettre sous pression Nemesis nul la
Pologne nulle j'ai jamais vu une équipe
aussi Reims
contre l'Argentine ils avaient fait une
première période à peu près correct et
puis en seconde période je sais pas
exactement les vestiaires l'histoire des
belles équipes c'est qu'elles ont
toujours tendance à faire voir les
autres équipes comme des équipes très
faibles oui parce qu'ils ont jamais
espéré parce que on leur a mis la tête
sous l'eau quoi c'est ça que vous me
dites
et on le voit tout au long du match même
s'il y a eu aussi il faut pas les nier
des petits périodes des flottements un
petit peu de bleu oh il s'était moins
présent mais c'est eux qui ont réussi à
dominer ces matchs et c'est grâce
également un flamboyant qu'il y en
Mbappé
tout de suite parce que évidemment c'est
lui la star de Smash et d'abord on
retrouve Vincent roseron Vincent avec
des supporters j'imagine forcément
heureux après cette victoire
et oui oui des supporters très très
heureux comme alors qu'est-ce que vous
avez pensé de ce match job The Voice
première mi-temps un peu en demi teinte
et puis ensuite kiki il a commencé et
puis ça y est c'est torché maintenant
j'espère l'Angleterre et puis comme ça
on continue on s'arrête plus on en est
déjà là mais attendez quand même ce
match on a quand même un peu souffert en
première mi-temps non non non c'est bien
passé après c'est on est en couple on
est en Coupe du monde là faut envoyer le
turbain et puis forcément il y a la
rivalité devant il y a il y avait qui il
y avait les rwandowski enfin il y a du
niveau un peu après on est en 8e le
niveau va augmenter petit à petit mais
non oui ok c'était un peu un peu chaud
mais on a dominé dans l'ensemble on a
dominé c'était tranquille et si je vous
demande le joueur du match je pense que
je vais deviner facilement ouais kiki
kiki vegan missile encore une fois il a
fait deux tiers de fou furieux
après il est un peu feignant un peu
feignant sur la gauche après je sais pas
pourquoi ils l'ont replacé au milieu sur
l'entrée je pense que ça a dû jouer et
ça ça sert à rien ça il faut qu'il reste
sur le côté quand il envoie ses missiles
là c'est bon dans la Lulu on en parle
plus c'est carré bon super merci
beaucoup en tout cas au revoir bonne fin
de mal bonne fin de journée voilà
des des grosses frappes dans la Lucas
c'est un vrai voilà
super star en France visiblement pour
tous les supporters je voudrais vendre
hommage à un homme
Emmanuel Macron vous savez ce qu'il a
dit
il parie chez nos confrères du Parisien
que la France l'emporterait trois buts
hein je pense qu'on gagne 3 les
vendeuses qui va en mettre un quand même
Mbappé ou peut-être Giroud et pas mal
quand même meilleur que vous non non
très très bon le président de la
République donc qui avait pronostiqué ce
score c'est ma fin de la qui me le
signale sur sur Le Figaro.fr vous
réagissez vous n'hésitez pas on continue
et donc on ouvre notre page Mbappé
forcément si Nicole Ménard et je vous
laisse la parole vous êtes son avocate
en même temps je suis pas sûr qu'il
aurait besoin
d'un avocat
tu es pas forcément conquis parce que
nous proposer le l'avant l'avant centre
l'attaquant des Bleus
pour vous c'est une star quoi point oui
en fait j'ai entendu tout à l'heure je
voulais ce peut-être d'avoir exprimé
votre avis pour que je puisse m'exprimer
les 20 premières minutes de la seconde
période Mbappé on peut sont mauvaises
oui je pense que c'est des mauvais
contrôles un agacement perceptible des
mauvais choix il ralentit le jeu avec
ses fins et tout alors on sait que c'est
un peu son jeu qui est toujours comme ça
mais là franchement pendant 20 minutes
ça a été du mauvais Killian je pense que
notre ami supporter c'est un peu ce
qu'il a noté aussi et puis voilà il y a
cette frappe au début de l'action je
trouve qu'il j'ai la sensation qui qui
tarde un peu et puis il envoie un
missile magnifique il y a un doublé il y
a une passe décisive après un moment
donné le pragmatique qui est en qui
sommeille en moi se dit voilà deux buts
une passe décisive en 8e de finale oui
c'est c'est l'heure du match mais il y a
20 minutes on débute seconde période on
peut pas dire qu'il a été construit il
revient à l'intérieur il fait une petite
talonnade pour personne il y a tous ses
défauts dans les 20 premières minutes de
là moi je veux dire c'est sur la
globalité si on regarde ces matchs il a
été très bon je vais vous dire pourquoi
alors certes je suis d'accord sur
l'effet qui a quelques déchets au niveau
des passes et des pertes des doigts ça
nous sommes tout d'accord on l'a vu les
mêmes maths on revendche et c'est là les
points forts dès qu'il y en AP c'est
qu'en fait il arrive vraiment à épuiser
l'adversaire avec ses courses avec ses
dribbles avec ses passements des jambes
l'action qu'on a vu enfin les superbe
buts on lui calme ça rien à dire mais
également quand il y a eu l'autre but de
premier c'est une belle action
collective c'est lui qui récupère les
ballons la belle passe de Dembélé donc
je pense que effectivement si on doit
vraiment parler du match des Killian
Mbappe la réalité c'est que il fait
briller de l'équipe de France et c'est
grâce à lui qui a un doublet et que nous
sommes effectivement
c'est évident vous voulez que je vous
dise que disent nos internautes
Mbappe point d'exclamation on a le Best
voilà ce qu'il dit qu'est-ce qu'on a Sam
V Mbappé notre trader national alors
Jérémy vous critiquez un peu il critique
Mbappé mais sérieux le gars se rend pas
compte de la machine qu'il est c'est
vrai que c'est une machine
c'est justement parce qu'on s'en rend
compte qu'on a un degré d'exigence qui
fait que c'est 20 premières minutes en
seconde période si franchement moi je
veux bien revoir avec ce monsieur les 20
premières minutes et qui me disent à
quel moment Mbappé fait des bons choix
joue bien sur ces résultats
[Musique]
qu'on a sauté de joie quand il a marqué
le deuxième but c'est pour ça qu'on ne
peut pas sortir Mbappé parce qu'il peut
faire 20 minutes 30 minutes 40 minutes
mauvaise et avec un coup de génie un
coup d'éclair il peut mettre d'accord
mais c'est vrai que les 20 minutes de la
deuxième mi-temps c'était voilà tous les
défauts de Mbappe les mauvais choix
ralentissement
parce que c'est un joueur et c'est là où
on voit encore sa jeunesse c'est pour ça
que il a vraiment ces pot les meilleurs
joueurs au monde je pense qu'il le
deviendrai c'est la et c'est en français
donc voilà
mais c'est pour ça parce que là
aujourd'hui on voit ça marche des
progressions et et c'est beau des voix
le temps des potentiels et ses erreurs
qui peuvent encore être corrigés qui
sont vraiment liés à ces jeunesse
il fait son boulot Cédric allier vous
avez
20 minutes de merde à chaque match comme
ça qui nous met un doubler jusqu'au bout
je suis d'accord comme vous vous
autorise une fois à dire un gros mot sur
tantôt et après c'est terminé voilà vous
l'avez fait je vous critiquerai et puis
maintenant vous le faites plus en
espagnol
je suis d'accord avec vous il a été
agaçant il a raté beaucoup de choses
pendant 20 minutes maintenant dites-lui
votre amour s'il vous plaît
déjà merci Kilian parce que
si on est en quart de finale je pense
que on lui doit on lui doit bien parce
que il a aussi fait deux premiers matchs
de phase de groupe qui ont été
excellents et puis voilà puis c'est
vraiment la star c'est l'homme décisif
c'est
pour en avoir parlé avec nos nos nos
envoyer spéciaux au Qatar tous les
journalistes arrêtent pas de leur
demander et tout il faut surtout pas
qu'il se blesse il faut voilà surtout ne
le tacle pas l'entraînement laissez-le
tranquille et tout et puis parce que
parce que illumine le jeu mais c'est ce
qui ronge justement quand il est moins
bon on voit que c'est tout le jeu de
l'équipe de France qui devient moins bon
même si après Griezmann a eu aussi une
importance très grande j'ai vu un
excellent radio mais je vais garder pour
après ce que vous allez me demander mais
pour l'instant on parle de Mbappé
Vincent roseron bapé à part ces 20
minutes déjà est-ce que vous l'avez
senti aussi comme ça et je dis cette
statistique qu'il a une Mbappé le
premier joueur de l'histoire inscrire 8
buts en Coupe du monde avant ses 24 ans
je crois que c'est 9 oui oui 9 buts en
11 matchs là maintenant
puisque 9 buts en match du monde
franchement Vincent dites-moi il vous a
agacé ou vous l'avez pas trop vu cette
ce déchet en début de seconde période
alors
si si on l'a vu en début de seconde
période et d'ailleurs avant son but
c'est assez fou parce que il fait cette
ce geste technique qu'il rate
complètement derrière il rate il pousse
un ballon un peu trop loin et il va pas
au pressing derrière il se fait
engueuler par Didier Deschamps
complètement il y a Marcus Thuram qui
arrive sur le banc on pense qu'il va
sortir et sur l'action d'après il marque
et des champs et lui parle et finalement
c'est Giroud et Dembélé qui sortent je
sais pas s'il voulait le faire sortir à
ce moment-là mais c'était assez fou
comme comme séquence il marque vraiment
au bon moment alors que on est en train
de se dire et ben assez bizarre on
pensait qu'il ratait tout et ben voilà
sur sur ça il gagne alors que genre
supporter derrière moi ah oui bonjour
monsieur
oh
bon ben il parlait pas vraiment français
comme vous pouvez le voir mais c'est
vrai vous avez souvent des supporters
français qui parlent pas français
du match
j'ai adoré ah regardez regardez j'ai un
supporter avec moi comment vous appelez
Monsieur Michel
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de ce
match c'est un match formidable et on
est hyper heureux
hyper heureux on se retrouve qui est
votre pour vous l'homme du match même si
je pense avoir qui c'est papy évidemment
mais Giroud a fait un match fabuleux
rabiot aussi sans oublier Hugo Loris qui
a fait les arrêts extraordinaires et
là-bas un peu fébrile en première
mi-temps et finalement il fait ce qu'il
faut mais c'est vraiment Mbappé qui
réussit le le cours du match oui c'est
l'homme du match et est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous avez été stressé un peu
au début du match non jamais non jamais
j'avais confiance bon ben super belle
sérénité en tout cas voilà vous voyez
beaucoup de supporters à côté de moi
merci beaucoup Thibault je vous laisse
repartir dans les canapés
Michel la force tranquille du supporter
français voilà parfait lui il était
peinard il a profité
Vincent roseron sur place on vous
retrouve
je lis ce que ce qu'on nous dit
prosternez-vous devant le prince Killian
c'est la star de la Coupe du monde pour
l'instant Florent c'est lui pour
l'instant oui avec Messi avec Messi mais
il a marqué plus de buts que Messi il
est plus déçu l'équipe de France je
trouve que Mbappe sans aucun sans aucun
concurrent je sais pas s'il est plus
décisifs que que Messi en termes de
chiffres il en est à 5 buts mais si si
je dis pas de bêtises c'est trois buts
une passe décisive
mais Mbappé doit avoir aussi une ou deux
pas ici dans les chiffres oui dans
l'influence sur le jeu mais si on a
l'impression que s'il est pas là il y a
plus d'Argentine effectivement et en
fait pardon pardon pardon c'est plus là
il y a une équipe de France plus que ce
que j'ai vu de l'Argentine jusqu'à
présent d'accord
vous êtes optimiste parce que moi c'est
Mbappé je peux vous Florent moi aussi je
suis pas très optimiste mais mais on a
quand même d'autres d'autres joueurs
Griezmann alors que vraiment on a
l'impression que tout le jeu argentin
passe par ici quoi mais vraiment c'est
pas une action à la piscine
très sauti d'ailleurs c'est l'un des
plus beaux matchs je trouve qu'on a vu
dans cette Coupe du monde et je trouve
que on Argentine il n'y a pas que Messi
justement il y a d'autres joueurs je
pense beaucoup et je l'ai dit je l'ai
dit ma callister qui vraiment a apporté
depuis qu'il est revenu avec l'équipe
d'Argentine parce qu'il était pas au
début là et vraiment ils ont une équipe
après une équipe de France la différence
c'est qu'on a des très grandes
individualités mais qui joue collectif
parce que on voit bien que dans les buts
c'est une construction collective et
c'est là qu'on arrive à voir les
dossiers vite de l'équipe de France donc
voilà c'est tout mis à jour 9 qu'il aime
Mbappé le premier joueur de l'histoire
inscrit 9 buts en Coupe du monde avant
c'est 24 ans qui dépasse donc un certain
Pelé c'est pas c'est pas rien et vous
voyez ici le classement des buteurs de
la Coupe du Monde Mbappé est en tête
Giroud et le talon Messi gagpo rachford
aussi je crois juste fontaine en termes
de meilleur buteurs en Coupe du monde
pour c'est vrai c'est à dire que
prochain but de Mbappé il sera le
meilleur buteur français à la Coupe du
Monde cette équipe de France on voit
d'ailleurs ça c'est un témoignage c'est
de non en haut du classement des buteurs
l'équipe de France marque des buts on
l'a dit des fois un peu ennuyeuses
franchement 4 buts contre l'Australie
bon la Tunisie on oublie le Danemark on
a été solide la 3 encore ce soir on
s'embête pas avec ces bleus ah comme en
2018 on les critique beaucoup beaucoup
mais c'est le système de jeu qui les qui
leur convient parfaitement donc comme on
a des flèches dans les couloirs qu'on a
un Griezmann qui construit le jeu on est
capable de transformer nos occasions en
but donc c'est pour ça qu'on est très
offensif on marque beaucoup on fait
plaisir même si on est parfois inquiet
moi je suis emballé par cette équipe de
France mais comme j'étais emballé en
2018 c'est-à-dire qu'on critique
beaucoup mais finalement le les
résultats le prouvent on s'ennuie pas
est-ce qu'on a vu plus fort que les
Bleus dans cette compétition
en plus on a ce défaut typiquement
français de de rabaisser les adversaires
maintenant ça y est on va dire que la
Pologne c'était nul enfin pardon oui là
je vais je vais me permettre de le dire
la Pologne c'était nul en première
période ça pas été nul la Pologne
attendait on a dit après notre première
victoire contre l'Australie 4 ans que
les Australiens
contre l'Argentine ils sont allés en 8e
donc au bout d'un moment si à chaque
fois on ne donne pas un peu de mérite à
cette équipe de France attendez qu'on en
vient à dire que c'est toujours le
mérite c'est d'être capable ce qu'on a
pas fait pendant des années de ne pas
tuer immédiatement une équipe plus
faible que nous et là on le fait elle
est plus faible elle est vraiment plus
faible comparé il faut pas rigoler
habituellement pas beaucoup non mais
rendez-vous compte quand même regarder
juste les derniers matchs il n'est pas
non plus habitué à encaisser autant donc
nos attaquants sont
très fort faut aussi les souligner bon
vous avez envie de dire que cette
Pologne était brillante ici je suis pas
certain gros exagéré
d'une certaine façon et effectivement
les Blue l'ont conduit petit appétit à
sortir de ces fameux blocs dans mon
passé qui était allé avoir pendant tous
les noms et vraiment ne pas être dans la
meilleure situation et c'est là où nous
on a réussi à prendre des temps on ne
peut pas dire que la Pologne était nulle
donc
je pense
mais le reste du match il est
extraordinaire bon bah la Pologne a fait
20 minutes avec la tête hors de l'eau
sinon c'était catastrophique
permettez-moi de vous le dire Vincent
roseau vous en pensez quoi vous pensez
que c'était un test vous le premier de
cette coupe du monde pour l'équipe de
France ou non toujours pas les Bleus
n'ont pas encore été vraiment testé
on va quand même dire je veux pas être
méchant envers nos amis polonais mais si
on rencontre l'Angleterre en quart de
finale ça a quand même avoir une autre
gueule c'est pareil le Danemark bon ils
ont fait sortir en plus c'était des
tests la bonne était un test au même
niveau je pense que que le Danemark pas
forcément beaucoup plus mais voilà les
vraies choses sérieuses on va dire ça a
commencé en car si on joue contre
l'Angleterre qui est une équipe vraiment
vraiment solide qui est un prétendant
final la Pologne n'est pas un prétendant
à la victoire finale comme peut l’être
l'Angleterre par exemple oui il faut
rappeler quand même forcément en test
pour moi
attendez je précise parce que Vincent
roseron nous parle de l'Angleterre il
faut que l'Angleterre parce que Sénégal
ce soir on en parlera juste après oui
bien sûr bien sûr
je sais Vincent que vous ne vous trompez
pas
vous trouvez que
c'est forcément un test dès qu'on est en
8e un match à l'hymne nation direct
qui est sorti d'une poule peut pas être
complètement
supporters est-ce que c'était un test
pour lui ce match ou pas vraiment
Vincent
alors je vais lui demander est-ce que
c'était un premier test pour l'équipe de
France ce match on avait déjà eu un
premier test contre le Danemark on avait
eu une grosse déception avec notre
équipe B contre la Tunisie mais il faut
reconnaître que lors de cette première
période on a eu 20 premières minutes on
a dominé on a pas marqué on a eu
vraiment peur de prendre ce premier but
et le but d'Olivier Giroud nous a un peu
libéré et après la classe de Kylian
Mbappé a fait la différence vous avez
été un peu stressé en début de match
c'est ça bien sûr avant de chaque match
à l'élimination direct de l'équipe de
France on est stressé mais Olivier
Giroud nous a libéré et Kylian nous
apaisé donc votre homme du match je
pense que je vais deviner qui c'est qui
Mbappé bien évidemment et la solidité de
l'équipe il faudra être un peu plus
solide en défense pour aller plus loin
et on sera là pour les cartes pour
souhaiter un équipe de France oui parce
que les gars ça risque d'être une autre
paire de manger ce serait une autre
paire de manche mais on sera là on sera
au rendez-vous et on va et cette fois-ci
on va pas dire voir
cette fois-ci on va essayer de pas
ramener la coupe à la maison mais de la
garder à la maison super merci beaucoup
merci oui il a raison enfin une autre
paire de manches nous verrons une en
plus tout le monde voit les Anglais mais
attendons il y a un match ce soir à 20h
tiens je risque on voit Christophe
remise et dans le stade Vincent vous
êtes devant pour rendre compte devant la
caméra de ce que vous avez vu Christophe
lui il est en conférence de presse il
est en zone mixte il recueille les
déclarations des joueurs et des
entraîneurs le talent à parler celui de
Killian Mbappe auteur d'un doublé pour
rassembler la Pologne et envoyer la
France en carte bonne deuxième période
des Bleus bien meilleur que la première
qualification logique mais pas sans
difficulté donc lui il trouve quand même
que il y a eu un petit test ça a pas été
une formalité quand on voit encore une
fois la première période oui on a
souffert mais je rappelle que souvent
l'équipe de France a du mal face à des
équipes qui sont moins bonnes on a
souvent dit on a ce que je veux dire
voilà maintenant on les écrase 3 donc on
va pas avec ça voilà vous avez raison ça
va être chaud contre les Anglais nous
dit deck une fois de plus attendez
attendez les Sénégalais n'ont pas dit
leur dernier mot ils ont un match à
jouer ce soir bravo les deux nous dit
Marie Bernier bon autre joueur doit
évoquer c'est évidemment Olivier Giroud
il entre dans l'histoire seul cette fois
52 buts en équipe de France buteur et un
peu blessé est-ce qu'on doit s'inquiéter
comme lors du premier match de des
blessures de les vieilles Giroud on sera
un peu fragile quoi non je sais pas ce
que vous en pensez c'est effectivement à
un moment d'aller Mathieu c'est touché
un peu la cuisse c'est un joueur qui est
déjà âgé et qui arrive tout déménagé moi
ce qui m'a fait vraiment rigoler entre
nous c'est que à un moment où il y avait
trois joueurs à la terre il tente quand
même ces gestes chromatique magnifique
avec pour essayer pour marquer c'est vu
et donc je trouve que c'est quand même
un joueur là c'est marrant
extraordinaire des faire cesser fort là
d'aller jusqu'au bout alors que
justement il a peut-être une gêne on a
des images à doigt devant le stade avec
des supporters français ce qu'on a le
son est-ce que on peut écouter oui on va
écouter on va essayer de s'imprégner de
l'ambiance devant le stade au Qatar
alors on va voir alors essayons quand
même Ryan Becker en régie
non on peut y aller c'est de l'ambiance
qu'est-ce que c'est oui c'est des gens
qui chantent bon je sais pas on va voir
si on arrive à trouver de l'ambiance bon
on continue Olivier Giroud vous est-ce
que
il vous rassure il ne vous inquiète avec
cette petite blessure là bon forcément
un petit peu inquiet mais il était déjà
il avait déjà cette petite gêne au
moment où il fait cette remise pour le
deuxième but de Mbappe Giroud il est
pour moi indispensable c'est-à-dire que
c'est un un joueur fantastique qui a la
niaque qui fixe les défenses qui
s'entendent très très bien avec Mbappé
avec Griezmann il nous libère en fin de
première mi-temps il fait ce geste
technique absolument incroyable à se
retourner on aurait dû y avoir un but je
sais pas si on va en discuter après mais
il fait ce geste incroyable et puis il
permet de faire cette remise qui amène
le but de map c'est un joueur
extraordinaire qui est rentré en plus
dans l'histoire
de l'ambiance devant le stade allons-y
on écoute
mais il semble y avoir des supporters
Vincent nous on a trouvé tiens ça peut
être un des petits débats qu'on va
ouvrir juste après on va finir le débat
sur Olivier mais justement j'en profite
cette ambiance dans le stade ça fait
quand même clairsemé c'est un peu triste
à voir cette ce 8e
c'est le moins
quand un joueur se tient derrière la
cuisse on pense tout de suite à un
problème musculaire et un problème
musculaire c'est jamais jamais très bon
signe après là la chance qu'on a là
maintenant c'est qu'on va avoir 6 jours
avant le samedi le quart de finale donc
on a 6 jours dont les sans doute les
deux prochains qui vont être très light
donc ils vont pouvoir ils vont pouvoir
lui faire un programme à la carte
je suis pas je suis ni Seraing ni
inquiet vigilant si vous motorisez
vigilant bien vous êtes un homme
vigilant Cédric Tellier bon on continue
à débriefer cette cette qualification
pour les quarts de finale de l'équipe de
France et ça c'est quand même la Bonne
Nouvelle on va faire rentrer notre
journaliste des réseaux sociaux tant il
soyez pour voir comment on réagit les
internautes évidemment et vous continuez
à réagir pendant ce débrief ce qu'on a
retrouvé le milieu de l'équipe de France
en deuxième mi-temps première mi-temps
c'était un peu fébrile notamment Antoine
Griezmann Griezmann une deuxième période
très costaud et d'ailleurs Cédric vous
l'a dit annoncé Griezmann va se prendre
de la dimension plus d'espace à l'aide
allez-y laisse Cindy
qui a été très beau et il y a d'autres
certitudes qu'on commence un petit peu à
se détacher et également Théo et un
indice qui a été bon ou pas mécano en
fait finalement c'est match ils sont
aussi servis donc rassurer par rapport à
ces 11 qui fonctionne des milliers
Deschamps et dont les joueurs montent un
petit peu aussi en puissance au fil et
aux missions de la compétition et
effectivement un point avec Griezmann
qui s'améliore et qui est très bon au
niveau des ruelles aussi
il a fait quand même un peu du travail
de l'ombre comme on dit mais en seconde
il s'est j'ai trouvé que c'était le plus
le plus régulier le plus
peut-être pas tranchant c'est pas le
terme mais en tout cas le plus influent
voilà de de ce milieu bien ce que
Griezmann fait une très bonne seconde
période en première on le voit pas trop
chomeny il est de la feuille vraiment de
dépassement de fonction il a été
précieux dans la récupération mais bon
il y a une frappe si en première période
mais on l'a pas 11 secondes période bon
il est sorti assez tôt mais moi j'ai je
suis content de voir un rabiot à ce
niveau-là et surtout on sent que match
après match on voit ce côté gauche
Mbappe rabio irlandaise qui qui vraiment
le on parle d'une dépendance de Mbappé
j'ai presque envie de l'élargir on a
presque une dépendance sur le côté
gauche quoi et rabiot aussi le travail
défensif parce que en duel face au
Polonais il était là il a il a amené
quelques ballons en touche il a bien
réussi à les aller sauver donc c'était
vraiment impressionnant à bio Vincent
roseron on va changer de plateau là dans
un instant enfin pas tout à fait on va
faire sortir Cédric alier à l'instant
pour faire entrer notre petit
chroniqueur notre journaliste Tanguy
soyez pour les réseaux sociaux vous avez
trouvé comment vous ce milieu de terrain
Vincent en deuxième mi-temps solide
alors ça peut être jouable ça peut être
jouable alors je sais plus je sais plus
où est le stade ce soir mais là on est
dans un stade qui est assez proche du
centre du du centre-ville là là on est
centre-ville donc en soit ce serait
possible que le match est dans deux
heures pour nous en tant que réalisateur
en tout cas on ne peut pas mais par
contre forcément c'est possible pour les
pour les pardon pour les supporters qui
sont encore un peu là comme vous avez pu
le voir derrière moi et qui sont encore
très contents de la de la victoire de
l'équipe de France merci Vincent on
revient vers vous tanguyez merci de nous
avoir rejoint alors sur les réseaux
sociaux est-ce qu'on s'est emballé
autour de ce match racontez-moi tout le
soulagement qui prédomine mais je vais
vous donner un chiffre 577 tweets par
seconde au moment du deuxième but de
Kylian Mbappe c'est colossal et c'est le
deuxième but le deuxième but la frappe
en pleine lucarne d'accord
ça montre les temps forts vraiment au
moment des buts alors au début qu'est-ce
qu'on a donc on vous remercie évidemment
notre partenaire notre outil de veille
sur des réseaux sociaux easy brain alors
effectivement ça nous montre le nombre
de postes
au moment des différents buts on voit
qu'évidemment il y a une explosion du
nombre de postes sur Twitter au moment
du double de Kylian Mbappé je le disais
mais aussi par exemple au moment où je
montrerai un tweet ensuite au moment du
but de Giroud annulé sur ah oui la
retourner acrobatique le fameux retourné
fabuleux je sais pas ce que vous en avez
pensé et peut-être que le but
de l'histoire de la Coupe du Monde qui a
été refusé
je suis assez d'accord alors ensuite si
on passe sur sur l'image d'après voilà
ça c'est assez intéressant aussi c'est
c'est les joueurs dont on parle le plus
sur les réseaux sociaux évidemment
en première place mais ce qui ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est Jules Kunde en
trois positions en 2e position c'est le
turquoise et donc
ça m'a ça m'a intrigué c'est peut-être
aussi pour le critiquer on sait qu'il a
été un petit peu en délicatesse sur ce
match là dans le sur le sur son côté
droit donc alors vous savez que depuis
qu'on a on vous fait venir là pour
débriefer le match les journalistes des
réseaux sociaux on voit c'est c'est
petit diagramme et donc souvent le
meilleur joueur est mis en exergue comme
ça et puis derrière il y a très souvent
des joueurs qui sont critiqués et
effectivement Ousmane Dembélé parce que
les internautes l'adorent toujours bon
effectivement il y a des éloges et puis
quelques fois les Twitter sont la plume
assez acerbe mais là notre confrère
encens ce Kylian Mbappe 23 ans poète
écrivain auteur compositeur interprète
et je crois que il a supprimé un tweet
mais je crois qu'il a même parlé
d'envoyer de Dieu sur terre donc voilà
c'est un petit peu emballé mais Mbappé
peut-être le prophète en tout cas il est
évidemment salué par par nos twitos on
va évidemment on va ensuite enchaîner
avec alors là je rentre dans la
catégorie des tweets un petit peu drôles
on voit Olivier Giroud encore une fois
les attendaient les wandowski mais ils
ont vu Gigi tu es plus beau que lui bon
bref c'est un truc assez grand que lui
tu marques plus de buts que lui tu es
meilleur que lui tout simplement c'est
toi le champion ah oui là c'est un
chemise et voilà c'est c'est oui c'est
winamax
mais c'est voilà c'est un tweet assez
drôle photo d'Olivier mannequin
classement pas de la comparaison avec le
golayador polonais
ensuite nous allons voir j'en parlais
tout à l'heure le fameux ciseaux
retourné
c'est à dire que souvent sur les retours
acrobatiques le ballon est à peu près
avec le tibia bon là elle est parfaite
quoi
dans les stats comme le but d'Antoine
Griezmann
officiellement ça fera 53 buts voilà
mais non non c'est vrai qu'il est
absolument très très réussi on enchaîne
avec d'autres réactions alors je sais
pas si vous avez constaté cela mais j'ai
le kunday avait oublié de d'enlever sa
chaîne lors de la première mi-temps et
ça a beaucoup oui amusé nos twitos alors
on l'a vu et puis on a fini par les
faire enlever tout à fait tout à fait
c'est un adjoint de Didier Deschamps qui
lui a enlevé vers la 40e minute si je me
trompe pas mais donc ça ça amusé ce
Twitter ce qui en a fait une partie et
peut-être qu'il était pas là c'est vrai
tout à fait sur sur son corps ensuite
quelques autres réactions encore et
d'ailleurs c'est ce que nous dit c'est
marrant ce que nous dit bgnp c'est à
cause de sa chaîne en or lorsqu'on
parlait lors des diagrammes tac il
réagit tu es plus rapide que vous voyez
si je vous laisse continuer et puis ce
dernier poste alors là ça m'a fait
sourire ça fera expliqué puisque alors
c'est un peu petit mais en gros il est
écrit que
l'arbitrage de ce soir c'est un
Venezuela était assez honteux et que en
gros il a voulu faire perdre la France
mais bon on lui en tiendra la rigueur
Wikipédia de l'arbitre France alors non
mais parce qu'il aurait fallu agrandir
l'image je suis désolé c'est de ma faute
mais il est écrit dans dans le bas de
l'image de l'article a été modifié comme
quoi c'est l'arbitrage était honteux
il était un petit peu anglais
c'est-à-dire qu'un peu laxiste il sait
faire après déjà dit longtemps bon à
part le but de Giroud mais bon ça moi je
dirais le carton jaune de 3 minutes est
un peu sévère mais sinon à part ça bon
j'ai pas trouvé qu'ils étaient
scandaleux cette arbitre Venezuela ne
nous déçoivent jamais sachez-le c'est
beaucoup la France d'ailleurs là il y
avait une expérience assez caricatural
je vous l'accorde mais voilà c'était
pour la c'était tout pour de température
aux côtés des twittos merci beaucoup
Tanguy soyez je retourne voir Vincent
roseron sur place Vincent vous nous
faites un petit point de ce que vous
avez vu je veux que vous me parliez
d'abord Mbappé parce que c'est ce qui
intéresse nos internautes ce que vous
l'avez trouvé bon l'ensemble de la
rencontre parce que sur ce plateau on a
vu qu'il y avait des bas est-ce qu'on a
des nouvelles de Olivier Giroud il est
sorti sur blessure dites-moi
alors on va commencer par mettre des
Killian Mbappé du coup Kylian Mbappé qui
fait quand même sur la globalité du
match un bon match puisque très bonne
passe décisive pour Olivier Giroud dès
le début en fin de première mi-temps
début deuxième mi-temps c'est assez
compliqué on l'a dit il a commencé à
faire du gesto technique alors que on le
comprend s'il est à deux ou trois zéro
il peut se permettre mais 1-0 un peu de
suffisance on va dire un peu trop
peut-être de il prenait un peu trop les
choses à la légère il est il y a sur un
sur un retour défensif il est pas revenu
il s'est fait engueuler complètement par
Didier Deschamps et en fait juste sur la
queue d'après Dembélé lui passe le
ballon et il marque c'est magnifique
victoire but donc de Mbappé doublé même
de Mbappé puis avec ce troisième but
plus tard vraiment un très très bon
match et sur Giroud j'ai malheureusement
pas de pas de nouvelles supplémentaires
pour vous mais Giroud voilà qui marque
du coup ce but ce qui le fait passer
devant Thierry Henry un but qui fait
extrêmement bien et qui est pas si
facile que ça à mettre en plus et par
contre parce que vous en avez parlé tout
à l'heure le retourner magnifique
retourné et vous demandez est-ce que ce
but était valable ou pas moi je pense
qu'il y a effectivement faute de Varane
mais pas sur le gardien en fait Varane
s'appuie sur le défenseur pour mettre la
tête se fait percuter par le gardien et
j'ai remarque derrière mais je pense
qu'effectivement il devait y avoir faute
sur le but de Giroud et c'est normal
qu'il ait été
refusé et si vous voulez quand je parle
un tout petit peu plus de l'Arabie je
suis d'accord avec ces 10 à jouer assez
à l'anglaise c'est à dire que sur le
début je me rappelle du d'action Mbappe
part dans la profondeur ma chicash lui
essaye de le rattraper de façon peu
conventionnelle on va dire et l'arbitre
laisse jouer il a fait ça quatre cinq
fois quand même durant le match et on a
senti que bon les Français étaient un
peu énervés au bout d'un moment par cet
arbitrage
merci Vincent roseron le service des
sports arrive en force sur ce plateau
Martin couturier le chef Teddy va des
Valou qui tape à chaque fois je vais
vous demander parce que ça
m'impressionne les matchs le live des
matchs et il écrit tout
sur les réseaux sociaux
Teddy vous vous avez rien vu vous tapez
sur votre clavier
non bah écoutez c'était un beau match
champion 2e période pour l'équipe de
France beaucoup plus rassurant après
voilà j'aime bien nuancer par rapport à
la faiblesse de l'équipe polonaise et si
vous les avez trouvé faibles je me tuais
à le dire à Florent baraque on n'est pas
totalement d'accord là-dessus non
surtout par rapport à la défense qui m'a
pas rassuré je pense que face à une
meilleure opposition on risque de on
risque de souffrir alors je sais pas ce
qui va arriver en car mais en tout cas
je trouve que on a encore un gros
problème en défense ouais bon et vous
Martin vous êtes pas d'accord les
Polonais vous avez trouvé bon
comme comme annoncé avant le début du
match dangereux en première mi-temps je
rappelle que le but de Giraud arrive
quand même très tardivement qu'on est
secoué qu'ils ont les Polonais ont pas
mal d'occasions quand même Teddy et donc
finalement au final on est quand même
aucune quoi
cache qui aurait pu être prise et une
occasion c'est une situation
ils en ont pris trois quand même les
Polonais ont joué le rôle de j'emmerde
pas d'accord ça peut mal tourner en
première mi-temps ça peut mal tourner
on est arrivé sur splatoon
fais pas les malins et je pense que les
Bleus ne font pas non plus les malins
sur le banc non non c'est c'est plus
serré finalement après en deuxième
mi-temps effectivement c'est sur
l'ensemble des 90 minutes on en a raté
20 minutes quoi bon maintenant un peu
plus que ça
un peu plus que ça honnêtement bon quel
joueur peut perdre sa place à parler de
parler de Giroud on va y revenir cette
équipe de France elle semble avoir
trouvé sa composition d'équipe il est
des chansons de l'avoir trouvé sa compo
est-ce que si vous deviez sortir un
joueur là vous faites un changement quel
selon vous n'a pas été au niveau dans ce
match allez Martin dites-moi alors moi
je peux sortir Kylian Mbappe parce que
finalement
il y a un ange
Martin alors
il y a pas grand monde à sortir même vu
le kunday moi il y a Ousmane Dembélé il
m'a pas 100% séduit vous aussi et en
plus on sait que derrière il y a un des
joueurs qui postulent le plus pour être
titulaire avec Kingsley coman n'a rien
montré de plus par rapport à Dembélé
Dembélé la agaçant mais en gros il y a
pas une grosse concurrence je vois pas
comment peut apporter de plus que
Dembélé le problème de Dembélé c'est que
quand il est dans un bonjour tout va
bien mais là dès ses premiers ballons on
sentait qu'il avait pas des sensations
et et il a pas pu euh
physiquement mal à l'aise c'est étonnant
Vincent roserand sur place vous quel est
le joueur qui vous a un peu déçu et qui
pourrait
ne pas être titulaire lors du prochain
match en quart de finale est-ce qu'il y
en a un qui est sur la sellette où ils
ont tous été bon ce groupe là c'est 11
vont aller au bout ensemble
[Musique]
j'aurai beaucoup de balles à vous en
trouver honnêtement parce que ils ont
été très bons ensemble j'ai trouvé pas
vraiment de maillon faible dans cette
équipe vraiment sur les latéraux Pavard
Pavard excusez-moi je suis le coude fait
quand même un bon match derrière
Hernandez aussi
défenseur central Varane sauve une
situation sur sa ligne Lloris il fait
des relances très approximatives en
première mi-temps mais il sort l'arrêt
qu'il faut avant qu'il faut le milieu de
terrain est solide et les attaquants on
a besoin voilà et où on a peut-être
Ousmane Dembélé mais encore Ousmane
Dembélé c'est pas non plus un mauvais
match et il a bien il a encore bien
défendu pendant ce match il faut aussi
en parler
on s'interroge sur le cydiaro.fr sur ce
but d'Olivier Giroud on en parlait juste
avant que vous arriviez était-il valable
ou non bon je vous propose qu'on note
les Bleus nos amis Christophe et
Baptiste les ont noté sur Le Figaro.fr
je vous donnerai leurs notes mais on va
remonter la liste vous donneriez combien
Hugo Lloris les amis
5 5 parce que au-delà il a fait des
bonnes parades il a fait des très belles
parallèles d'ailleurs mais en dehors de
ça il a pas respiré la sérénité j'ai
trouvé assez fébrile sur les sorties
aériennes en début de matchs
un peu le fil mais après c'est bien il
s'est bien rattrapé donc sans que ça me
paraît une bonne note moi je suis embêté
parce que j'ai relu le papier qui est
sur le web déjà et qui sera dans le
journal de demain
ils ont mis cinq aussi
il fait quand même un magnifique arrêt
2e s'il le connaissent il a arrêté
le penalty bon Jules kunday combien vous
lui donnez Florent
moi je vais être méchant et que je me
coudée il m'est arrivé pendant le match
je regrettais Benjamin Pavard donc c'est
pour dire si si ça si ça allait mal moi
je l'aurais mis entre 3 et 4 plutôt 4
parce qu'on a gagné mais je trouvais
qu'il y avait des absences défensives il
n'apporte presque rien offensivement il
y a des moments où Dembélé avait le
ballon il tournait sa tête et il y avait
il y a jamais eu Jules kunday donc
c'était compliqué à vous donner quatre
c'est un gros problème ce couloir droit
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant ce que ce
qu'ils écrivent et vous pouvez retrouver
sur papier sur sur Le Figaro.fr
évidemment une prestation qui n'est pas
de nature à mettre fin au débat avec
Benjamin Pavard encore que c'est Axel
disasy qui a remplacé kunday pour les
ultimes minutes de la rencontre je pense
que Benjamin Pavard et doit être dans
une situation mentalement
pas évidente après son premier match
manqué donc je pense que là
malheureusement il passe en troisième en
troisième rang des latéraux droit donc
ça doit payer ça doit pas être une
situation facile à vivre maintenant on
peut avoir oui c'est assez étrange quand
même ce choix de le mettre au troisième
rang parce que je trouve enfin il s'agit
n'est pas un spécialiste du poste de
latéral droit comme ne l'était pas
kunday alors que Pavard a joué plus
souvent ce poste Raphaël Varane tiens je
commence par Vincent roseron combien
vous lui donneriez au boss de la défense
des Bleus qui semble retrouver du rythme
non
il retrouve du rythme il retrouve de la
sérénité mais en même temps c'est pas
encore vu alors je lui mettrais moins
coupable quand même même si il a il a
bien géré les wandowski et surtout en
fait s'il fait ce sauvetage chevaline
qui veulent lui valoir deux points de
plus surtout donc je vais aller au moins
6 je pense 6 pour 20 € oui c'est vrai
que ce sauvetage sur la ligne il est il
est majeur juste après l'arrêt d'Hugo
Lloris vous lui donnez-vous aussi 6 et
bien 6 oui si ça me paraît oui ça me
paraît et bien figurez-vous qu'il lui
ont donné cinq à Raphaël Varane tout
comme à d'ailleurs tu peux pas mecano 5
peut-être que j'aurais donné
qui est pour moi m'a rassuré et a fait
un match solide vous voulez dire que
nous aurez spéciaux oui alors je vais
leur faire un message on ne voit pas
tout à fait le même match c'est toujours
ce qu'on dit devant la télé au stade
c'est pas tout à fait
dire dans mon oreille je viens de
l'entendre
[Musique]
face à l'Australie il était dans son
rôle mais il a pas fait non plus de
d'exploit ou de choses qui m'ont
impressionné disent que Varane peut
apporter plus que le leader de la
défense vu son expérience doit
finalement entre guillemets muscler un
peu son jeu et est encore un petit peu
en jeu attention Aurélien quelle note
est-ce que vous lui donnez Teddy moi je
l'aurais donné 5 et demi 6 j'en ai deux
notes donc je l'ai trouvé plus discret
que Radio 75
j'ai trouvé plus discret que rabios à
ses côtés et je trouve qu'il joue pas
dans son registre habitué je le trouve
un peu un peu encore timide en équipe de
France je j'attends plus de lui qui
prennent plus de responsabilités après
c'est peut-être une consigne de la part
de Deschamps de pas de oui il y a
beaucoup d'attaques qui défendent plus
que qui n'attaque quoi Martin
assez d'accord avec Teddy va dévalous
sur ce coup-là je dois reconnaître après
je trouve qu'on vous trouvez vous
il prend un jaune qui est très sévère
alors là
j'ai pas trouvé globalement l'arbitre
très bon moi à vous aussi oui bon j'ai
trouvé que souvent Mbappé était pas gâté
dans l'arbre pas assez protégé
non j'ai pas trop qui était bon garçon
moins libre après son quartier
maintenant que Cindy vous pouvez le dire
et des internautes l'ont beaucoup
critiqué
le carton jaune est un peu sévère moins
libre après son carton jaune il a céder
sa place à la 66e Aurélien de choix
Menini qui avait été titulaire le seul
titulaire sur les quatre matchs des
Bleus donc c'est aussi pour ça sans
doute que disait Deschamps l'a fait
sortir dès qu'il a pu Adrien rabiot bon
match d'Adrien rabiot Vincent roserand
vous lui donnez combien à Adrien
je me permets de l'appeler Adrien un peu
plus alors j'ai pas entendu la note de 3
mini mais du coup moi je mettrais allez
6 à 3 mini ou 5 et demi et si c'est demi
à la Radio 7 il donne 7 à Adrien rabiot
discret mais précieux voilà ce qui nous
disent c'est son nouveau rôle lui qu'on
sait toujours un peu en fait difficile à
cerner parce qu'il parle beaucoup parce
qu'il a des petites sorties là rabiot
dans son élément on l'a dit tout à
l'heure en première période il a été
solide offensivement défensivement il
fait un bien fou à il fait un bien fou à
cette équipe et c'est vrai que il il
comment dire il éclipse un peu de choix
mini je trouve dans sur ce match et sur
les matchs précédents c'est vraiment la
satisfaction de cette Coupe du Monde on
le connaissait évidemment le PSG la Juve
tout ça mais vraiment c'est sa coupe du
monde en bleu avec bon d’autres mais
vraiment c'est une des belles très
belles satisfactions de ce début de
coupe du monde je trouve qu'il a
progressé dans l'attitude aussi je le
trouve un peu moins non blanc il est
libre bien l'équipe en plus quand quand
Mbappé des fois se glisse dans l'axe il
glisse à gauche je trouve que non il est
il fait une coupe du monde parfaite pour
l'instant il est présent défensivement
et offensivement il est exactement
Monique nous Tence oh arrêtez de
critiquer à si tranquillement sur une
chaise très facile de noter oui très
vrai ça il y a pas de problème non il y
a les blancs on fait un bon match c'est
vrai et on leur donne plutôt des des
bonnes notes Antoine Griezmann tiens
intéressant là de le noter Antoine
Griezmann parce que sa première mi-temps
franchement pas bonne sa deuxième est
excellente laquelle des deux a fait la
différence selon vous Martin
la question car j'ai un appel de
quelqu'un du journal il faut que j'aille
m'occuper du de la page donc je vais
être obligé de vous laisser bien sûr
quelle était la question et bien je veux
savoir quelle note donner à Antoine
Griezmann avant de remonter Christiane
on va lui mettre
6 ou 7 c'est pas le meilleur match de
grisou il a été assez discret en
première mi-temps assez
c'est dans la nasse il a pas réussi à
s'en dégager après il est un petit peu
plus d'espace effectivement après le
repos donc ça a été un petit peu mieux
après allez je vais lui mettre 6 bon la
note que vous donnez à Antoine Griezmann
on va avoir les premières déclarations
qui tombent on va aller les lire
ensemble notamment Didier Deschamps qui
viennent à cette capacité à résoudre
beaucoup de problèmes oui c'est joli
Mandy Vincent roseron
vous donnez quelle note à Antoine
Griezmann vous avez vu aussi un
Griezmann à double face
Griezmann double face une première
mi-temps où il était loin de son niveau
où il était plutôt irréficie pas tout
techniquement il avait un peu du mal à
se placer et après deuxième mi-temps il
a été étincelant c'était assez on a
retrouvé le Griezmann habituel donc je
lui mettrais quatre en première 8 en
deuxième ça nous fait un six au final et
vous me dites pareil Florence
un petit peu plus libéré il a pu
distribuer mieux le jeu et moi je
retiens vraiment cette relance il est
dans le camp dans le camp dans la
surface de réparation française il fait
cette relance sur Giroud c'est ça qu'on
aime c'est pas me dire qu'il fait
quelque chose de non mais
dégage les yeux fermés
dans les écoles de football Giroud sauve
cette balle qui lui tourne dans les
pieds depuis le début vous n'aimez pas
cette équipe de France
mais ne donnez pas des points Antoine
Griezmann pour une relance à deux doigt
d’être catastrophique et qui a
maintenant catastrophique je
taquine évidemment alors je suis très
surpris par la note
Ousmane Dembélé parce que on l'avait pas
trouvé de nous transcendant Ousmane
Dembélé vous en pensez quoi vous alors
moi je voudrais donner 4 enfin je
l'aurais pas donné la moyenne en fait
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure il a il
a très mal débuté son match et ça a
donné le ton en fait du du reste de sa
prestation avec beaucoup de dribbles
voilà de conduite de enfin surtout ça
conduite de balles qui m'a qui m'a déçu
en poussant trop loin son ballon sur
beaucoup d'action qui était intéressant
pour nous donc non je l'aurais pas donné
la moyenne il lui en donner 6,5 vous
trouvez que c'est beaucoup aussi
mais bon ils disent une frappe un peu
molle mais il est pasteur décisif sur le
deuxième but français et une vraie passe
mais c'est une passe non attendez
au moins 30 secondes avant de frapper
mais c'est lui qui fait quand même la
différence il a un boulevard Mbappé
grâce à cette passe qui est au bon
moment dans le bon timing il faut le
dire oui
bons de différence sur cette passage
j'ai pas l'impression mais
mais c'est vrai que le côté droit est
compliqué pour pour les Bleus entre
Jules kunday ou Ousmane Dembélé on
parlait tout à l'heure vous nous
demandiez qui on pouvait voilà c'est ce
côté-là qui effectivement pose je pense
à ces problèmes
on regarde la déclaration d'Olivier
Giroud et puis on s'interrogera sur la
note à donner à l'avancement des Bleus
ils nous ont mis en difficulté mais on a
eu un bel esprit défensif j'avais
vraiment envie de conclure c'est que du
bonheur et oui évidemment Olivier Giroud
qui devient l'unique meilleur buteur de
l'histoire de l'équipe de France quelle
note vous lui donnez fort en baraco ah
moi j'aurais tendance à lui donner 8 il
va m'en faire un super match c'est lui
qui débloque la situation
il fait cette ce retourner à chromatique
alors bon certes il y a pas but mais bon
il fait quand même le un geste sublime
s'en souviendra on se dit tu deviens
zlatanesque
et puis trois quart d'heure quand il
fait son patron
ne me faites pas croire ça marche pas
combien vous lui donnez Olivier alors
sortez-moi un ballon et on va vous le
faire là tout de suite
attendez on est prêt à le faire rester
avec nous et on reste encore une dizaine
de minutes ensemble dans 10 minutes
Martin couturier se fera extrêmement mal
au dos dans le salon allez-y donnez-moi
une note pour Olivier moi je dirais 7
c'est bien ça c'est bien moi c'est
pareil parce que alors il a fait il a
ouvert le score ce qui est le plus dur
dans un dans ce genre de match c'est
voilà c'était vraiment le plus important
après oui enfin il participe au jeu il a
touché que 19 ballons dans ce match
c'est bien si j'ai bien retenu les
chiffres 9 en 1re période après oui il
est là au bon moment mais sept je trouve
que c'est c'est très bien et bien c'est
la note que qu'on donnait Christophe et
Baptiste à Olivier Giroud 7 bon et puis
l'homme du match qui vient de Mbappé
quand on met en quart de finale un
doublé et qu'on donne une pâte dessus
après avoir gagné un match trois buts
quel nom quelle note doit-on recevoir te
dit 9 9
je trouve qu'il est il est dans dans la
lignée de ce qui fait notamment en club
ou Paris Saint-Germain il est là quand
on l'attend
la pression glisse sur lui j'ai
l'impression et voilà et je pense qu'il
adore ce genre de moment la Coupe du
Monde il
un peu on va dire on va dire ça lentille
il était très très agacé Mbappé a perdu
la balle sur la geste technique puis
derrière il pousse son ballon trop loin
le défenseur polonais le récupère et lui
il va pas du tout précis il s'arrête
complètement il marche il garde la tête
basse et des gens n'a pas du tout aimé
ça et on a même et à ce moment-là il y a
comme un et tu rames qui arrive sur le
banc et il fait venir et on se dit
vraiment vraiment qui va et qui va le
faire sortir et 30 secondes plus tard et
ben il marque cette magnifique frappe en
lucarne et donc voilà du coup il reste
sur le terrain et il fait il fait un
excellent match je suis entièrement
d'accord avec avec cette note moi je
pense que neuf c'est très bien et une
pensée pour ce pauvre petit matin
latéral polonais qui va en faire des
cauchemars parce qu'il est quand même
terminé sur les fesses pendant les 20
premières minutes je crois qu'il tombe
deux fois sur des dribbles de Mbappe lui
a fait vivre un véritable calvaire
c'était franchement assez triste à voir
pour lui ah ouais vous trouvez nous on
l'a trouvé plutôt bon bah bon
il a payé cash il fallait la faire bien
vu je sentais qu'il y avait une envie je
vais juste rajouter
non je suis déçu de au-delà de la
défense de l'impact des remplaçants des
jours qui sortent du banc et je trouve
que coman tuera à chaque fois font pas
des entrées inoubliables et des fois
pour la suite il y a 11 joueurs et puis
c'est tout franchement là pour le coup
on le constate oui bon je pense qu'ils
sont capables tous de faire encore quoi
3 matchs maintenant pour être champion
du monde bon une petite semaine de repos
et ça ira allez on se projette justement
sur la suite il y a un quart de finale
ce sera donc samedi prochain 20h 20h
donc ce sera en rendez-vous non oui on
sera là évidemment vous voulez qui ce
sera l'Angleterre ou le Sénégal
vous voulez qui est vous pensez que ce
sera qui te dit tiens moi je pense que
ce sera l'Angleterre alors évidemment
c'est la grande favorite pour ce soir
mais oui je pense l'Angleterre de
Sénégal même sans maner je trouve et
assez faible et l'Angleterre a quand
même un gros pot possède sur toutes les
toutes les lignes
après ça a été moins bon mais je pense
que c'était plus de la gestion qu'autre
chose et qui montreront autre chose ce
soir d'ailleurs et ça promet ça promet
un très beau duel et vous aimeriez avoir
le Sénégal quand même ou non vous dites
allez ça y est moi je moi je j'aime bien
au début et puis après au bout d'un
moment on a envie de s'amuser un peu
quoi les Anglais bon bah français
l'Angleterre donc qu'on sait pas croiser
d'ailleurs en grande compétition en
grande compétition
il y avait eu l'euro évidemment
Martin vous voulez qui vous l'Angleterre
ou le Sénégal et puis vous pensez que
l'Angleterre va l'emporter sur lui on va
dire l'Angleterre pronostic facile je me
suis totalement trompé pour la Pologne
donc il y a pas de raison vous avez vu
que c'est quand même notre ami il est
président qui avait raison on l'a dit
absolument et plus dans les buteurs
même le buteur polonais oui vraiment il
sait pas non plus
moi j'adore que les confrontations
France-Angleterre que ça soit en rugby
que ça soit en foot nos meilleurs
ennemis c'est vrai ça va être chaud ça
va être bien en plus il y a pas trop de
willigan cette année donc on peut
espérer qu'il y aura que ça sera assez
calme dans les dans les tribunes et
ailleurs tiens d'ailleurs Vincent
roseron il y a des supporters anglais
vous envoyez beaucoup ou pas autant que
les Argentins peut-être
pas autorisation ça c'est sûr parce que
les Argentins ils sont très très
nombreux je pense que les argentins et
les Brésiliens c'est les plus nombreux
beaucoup de beaucoup de tunisiens et
marocains on a vu aussi mais les Anglais
oui il y en a quand même pas mal il y en
a quand même pas mal dont d'ailleurs sur
des sur des yachts énormes en fait il y
a des il y a des Yot il y a des bateaux
de croisière qui sont
dans le port de doigt et qui accueille
beaucoup beaucoup d'anglais qui restent
sur place voilà c'est assez c'est assez
pratique pour eux on va dire mais donc
oui pas mal d'anglais et par contre
c'est vrai que ce que disait Martin on
est sur une coupe du monde très très
calme pas de débordement du tout du tout
du tout pour l'instant anglaise si les
Anglais oui si les Anglais remplissent
un stade avec des gens qui viennent de
yacht vraiment je pense que les Catari
doivent se réjouir vous voulez qui vous
Florent barako bonjour les Sénégalais
moi je voudrais régler un vieux compte
de 20 ans Sénégal donc on avait perdu en
ouverture de la Coupe du monde mais non
je pense que ce sera les Anglais ce
seront les Anglais qui c'est vrai que ça
aussi
c'était terrible on devait remporter
cette deuxième étoile mais non les
anglais sont plus forts je pense et je
pense que pour le spectacle c'est quand
même avoir un bon France Angleterre
c'est toujours bien Vincent roserand et
puis je vais vous libérer vous vous les
avez vu d'ailleurs est-ce que vous avez
la chance de voir les Anglais jouer
depuis le début de cette compétition au
stade l'entend et où les Sénégalais
d'ailleurs parlez nous deux
et bien non c'est les deux équipes que
j'ai pas vues
non non mais par contre j'ai vu j'ai vu
par contre certains matchs du du Sénégal
pas au stade par contre j'ai vu les
Anglais contre l'Iran qui a été un très
très bon match mais bon c'était c'était
lire en face moi je verrai bien enfin
forcément moi je préfère vraiment que ce
soit l'Angleterre pour avoir un vrai
choc sans faire offense bien sûr au
Sénégal mais je pense que les Sénégalais
ils ont quand même montré des belles
choses j'ai vu la fin du match qu'ils
ont fait c'était contre voilà l'équateur
l'équateur c'était quand même très très
sympa voilà même si c'était que
l'équateur ils peuvent poser des
problèmes à mon avis à cette équipe
anglaise et pourquoi pas aller se
qualifier en quart de finale allez un
petit prono pour le match de ce soir
Teddy
pour les Anglais Martin 3 3 pour les
Anglais ce sera certainement pas ça ne
pariez pas chez vous Martin couturier et
très mauvais en pari sportif allez-y je
prends beaucoup de risques un partout et
victoire des Anglais à la prolongation
donc 1er match qui va en prolongation
dans cette chemise là j'aime beaucoup ça
bon faudra se veiller un peu tard allez
cette équipe de France parce que j'ai
pas eu votre avis là-dessus est-ce
qu'elle a vraiment été testé est-ce que
ça y est là on peut vraiment voir le
niveau de cette équipe ou non la Pologne
c'est encore trop faible
moi j'ai envie de dire qu'on ne sait pas
tout sur cette équipe de France encore
il y a eu des manques sur ce match là il
y a eu des faiblesses on l'a vu il a
failli avoir des buts quand même il y a
toujours un but encaissé d'ailleurs
depuis le début de la compète si je dis
pas de bêtises par les Bleus c'est ça
devant sa fonctionne bien ça on le
savait il y a quand même un côté qui
fonctionne aussi compliqué
non moi je pense qu'on n'est pas testé
encore
il faut voir face à des plus gros de
plus gros on a été testé quand même avec
le Danemark mais qui a été quand même
marqué
au travers mais peut-être que c'est dû
aussi à notre force collective
donc pour moi on n'a pas encore été
testé c'est pour ça que j'attends ce
quart de finale avec impatience merci
beaucoup merci de nous avoir suivi allez
je montre quand même cette déclaration
d'Adrien rabiot on lui laisse la parole
il a été bon l'ancien joueur du
Paris-Saint-Germain le joueur de la
Juventus de Turin on est prêt vous
présenter n'importe qui nous allons
marcher sur le monde
c'était la suite merci beaucoup Florent
pago directeur adjoint du figaro.fr
merci au service des sports Martin
couturier le chef Teddy va de Valou le
liveur merci Vincent roseron profitez
bien vous restez une semaine de plus
bravo vous avez gagné votre votre place
votre semaine de vacances merci beaucoup
je sais qu'il travaille beaucoup Vincent
roseron Mercier Ariel Becker merci à
Julien Leclerc merci Augustin morio
merci à Vincent roux toute la rédaction
du Figaro à Sandrine aussi qui nous
maquille pour nous rendre un peu moins
vilain on se retrouve évidemment la
semaine prochaine pour le foot et puis
on reste ensemble parce qu'on va parler
de politique dans quelques minutes les
LR choisissent leur président il y a un
deuxième tour ce petit Retailleau ce
sera le match et on va débriefer tout ça
tout de suite merci beaucoup